WE APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US ON
"HANNITY" TO GO OVER IT.
ALSO, NEW DOCUMENTS OBTAINED BY
JUDICIAL WATCH REVIEW HOW IT
REPORTERS FOR THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS APPEARS TO PUSH
THE FBI TO PROSECUTE
PAUL MANAFORT.
JOINING ME NOW WITH MORE
REACTION OF THIS AND MUCH, MUCH
MORE IS JUDICIAL WATCH
PRESIDENT TOM FITTON AND
AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE UNION
CHAIRMAN MATT SCHLAPP.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I'VE GOT TO GO TO YOU FIRST.
YOU JUST PUT THIS INFORMATION
OUT.
WHAT DID THE AP DO ACCORDING TO
WHAT YOU BEEN ABLE TO SEE IN
TRYING TO MANIPULATE AN
INVESTIGATION INTO PAUL MANAFOR
PAUL MANAFORT?
>> JUST BEFORE MUELLER WAS
APPOINTED, THEY MET WITH ANDREW
WEISSMANN WHO WAS A SENIOR
JUSTICE OFFICIAL AND THE BOTTOM
INFORMATION INCLUDING THE CODES
TO MAN UP MANAFORT
'S STORAGE LOCKER.
THAT WAS HELPFUL.
AND THEY SAY TO THEM, GO BACK TO
CYPRUS AND MAKE SURE THEY GAVE
US ALL THE INFORMATION WE NEED.
SO YOU HAVE THE AP GOING IN,
GIVING THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INFORMATION TO TARGET
MANAFORT -- MAINLY TO GET TRUMP,
OBVIOUSLY.
THE AP REPORTERS ACCORDING TO
THIS FBI MEMO OF THE MEDIA
MEETING WITH WISEMAN
ANDREW WEISSMANN,CAN THERE BE AF
ANDREW WEISSMANN,CAN THERE BE AL
ANDREW WEISSMANN,CAN THERE BE AE
ANDREW WEISSMANN,CAN THERE BE AS
ANDREW WEISSMANN,CAN THERE BE AA
ANDREW WEISSMANN,CAN THERE BE AE
ANDREW WEISSMANN,CAN THERE BE AT
PROSECUTION?
CAN YOU TELL ME WHETHER IT CAN
BE ENFORCED?
THEY ARE PUSHING CHARGES ON THIS
AMERICAN CITIZEN!
ON WHAT PLANET IS IT ETHICAL FOR
GENERALISTS TO DO THIS?
AND THE WEISSMANN ASSIGNING THEM
TO CONTACT THE FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT TO GET DIRT ON THE
PRESIDENT'S FORMER CAMPAIGN
MANAGER.
THAT WAS JUST A FEW DAYS BEFORE
MUELLER WAS APPOINTED, AFTER
LISTENING TO SIDNEY, AFTER
SEEING WHAT I'VE SEEN HAPPENED
WITH THE MANAFORT ABUSES, THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD LOOK AT
SERIOUSLY PARDONING ALL THESE
FOLKS CAUGHT UP IN MUELLER'S WEB
AND THE DEEP STATE WEB AND THE
OBAMA WEB, YOU NAME IT.
THE ABUSE OF POWER, THE
PROSECUTORIAL ABUSES ARE
HE SHOULD BE FREEZING THE FLYNN
PROSECUTION AND INVESTIGATING
WHAT WENT ON THERE.
>> Jason: MATT, I WAS LOST
WHEN TALKED ABOUT THE
DEEP STATE, THEY WOULD JUST
LAUGH AT YOU.
BUT NOW HERE WE ARE TODAY.
ALL THIS EVIDENCE THE MOUNTAINS
OF.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE NADLER AND
SCHIFF, SAYING ALL THIS IS
POLITICAL ON TRUMP'S PART.
HOW DO YOU REACT WHEN YOU SEE
ALL OF THIS?
>> LIKE YOU, I'VE RESISTED SOME
OF THIS DEEP STATE LINGO.
I THINK THE SWAMP PEOPLE HAD IT
ALL WRONG.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS LIKE, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE PAY TO PLAY IN
WASHINGTON.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE SWAMP IS
SOMETHING THAT'S INCREDIBLY
SERIOUS, WHICH IS EVEN WHEN
REPUBLICANS WOULD MAKE THE
PRESIDENCY, THE LEFT CONTROLS
THE CITY.
THEY CONTROL ALL THE WHITE
BUILDINGS, THEY CONTROL ALL THE
AGENCIES BECAUSE THE PLACE WHERE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RECRUITS
FROM OUR VERY BLUE AREAS.
NORTHERN VIRGINIA, WASHINGTON
AND WASHINGTON, D.C.
YOU KNOW, I THINK ABOUT
PAUL MANAFORT.
I MET WITH SOMEBODY WHO HAS
KNOWN THAT FAMILY A LONG TIME.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE
LIKE MIKE FLYNN AND
PAUL MANAFORT WHO DARE TO
ASSOCIATE THEMSELVES WITH
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE HE WAS
GOING TO COME IN LIKE RECKITT
WRECK-ITTRALPH AND THAT'S WHY TE
WRECK-ITTRALPH AND THAT'S WHY TY
WRECK-ITTRALPH AND THAT'S WHY TP
THE PRICE.
IF MIKE FLYNN HAD GONE TO
RETIREMENT AND PAUL MANAFORT
WOULD'VE NEVER COME BACK TO
POLITICS THEY WOULD'VE HAD THE
WONDERFUL RETIREMENT.
THEY HAD THE AUDACITY TO HELP
DONALD TRUMP AND THAT WAS
UNFORGIVABLE TO THE DEEP STATE,
THE SWAMP, AND THESE DISGUSTING
ACTORS IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAVE TO KEEP SAYING IT,
JASON.
THIS ALL HAPPENED UNDER
BARACK OBAMA.
I BELIEVE BARACK OBAMA KNEW WHAT
EXACTLY THE WRONG DOING OR AT
LEAST NEW IN A BROAD SENSE THE
WRONGDOING THAT TOOK PLACE TO
TRY AND STOP TRUMP AS A
CANDIDATE AND IS A NEW
PRESIDENT.
AND THIS IS DISGUSTING.
SOMEBODY HAS TO PAY OR IT WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN TO A FUTURE
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
>> Jason: I THANK YOU.
I WISH I COULD SPEND THE WHOLE
HOUR JUST TALKING TO THE TWO OF
YOU WITH YOUR WEALTH OF